uh were ideal targets are gonna be here
on these veins and arteries on the neck
is a good one uh Bridge of the nose is
always a good one there's bitter strikes
I think for the temple
you can have underneath the rib cage too
on the rib cage okay so here
boom Bridge of the nose boom on the rib
cage okay
um you have to be compact so none of
this stuff don't show your face and you
have to make sure that you're not
risking the frail the Frailty of the
inner deltoid and those connective
tissues there so type
comes up guarding
your elbow will come in
to protect those tissues there and so
your elbow will be down
good
all right let's try Okay a couple things
to remember uh
this two coming out and exposing
yourself you want to understand your
outer rim okay your uh elbow can't ever
go outside your outer rib so you're out
of a rib the lateral borders of your
outer rim is your shoulder oh the same
thing goes when you strike you can't
strike past your shoulder you guys see
that
uh and then remember your fourth engine
so your Force engines are not going to
be you coming here
doing a an external Force engine you're
gonna you're gonna have to ground boom
you're going to feel the resistance of
the young aspect of the bag or the
Target that has to go down Pull and
project back out okay
you also have your quad so you can
you're not going to turn
your your waist
nor not turn it off and it's just
Johanna
and then to that you do have some
marriage with gravity so my heel is up
as I'm sliding in and as it drops you'll
see my Center drops two in there okay so
you combine all that again boom pop
no
no okay
foreign
the weapon itself is this bottom side
portion of your hand
do not hit with this side this upper
side portion
okay it's down here it's almost like a
heel Palm on the side so this is
incorrect making that incorrect so you
have to pull it back
to get that formation
here
incorrect incorrect
here so you hit here
here
incorrect
boom
all right here we go uh so when it comes
to striking you can't strike then this
is important all right you you cannot
strike every any anywhere you cannot
strike anywhere that you would do an
Aikido naginawasa
okay because of the spinal displacement
right so as as he's finally displacing
with some aggression
that'll smother my strike
thank you
they don't coexist
in the forms right so like for example
when you're doing a form you'll see a
strike you'll see some strike you see
that but the forms aren't self-defense
situations they're not applications it's
better to think of the forms as like a
myth in uh the Scholastic study of
Religion that kind of myth all right
they're they're kind of just markers so
if you if you read verses of the Bible
it doesn't make sense to read it
literally uh they're just kind of
sticking in things so if you go like I'm
going to read it literally and you try
to find like a timeline it's it's not
going to work it doesn't work things get
stuck in they're like Place markers for
ideas so that strike in ikyo is a place
marker uh that's not necessary when
someone grabs you here and there's
finally displays from stripe it's a
place marker for there is something
called the Timmy uh it does work in an
interrelated way with your nagewaza Etc
it doesn't mean that's what you do so
what you want to understand at a
practical level anything where I would
be able to companies coming in anything
that I would be able to throw I would
not be able to strike so the idea that
um he's he comes in and I go to throw
and he resists and you're gonna do it to
me and then the throne no you're not
no you're not do you guys understand
that okay
so uh
you can't do it under pressure
there's several ways that you're not
under pressure
you can uh get yourself to a sweet spot
uh so let's say he's doing that same
thing but he felt
um
he he was like half-assed kind of
half-assed you get it so he comes in I
move boom and then I can get that
um or he never meant his finally display
so that was a half-assed final he's kind
of cautiously coming in boom you can get
yourself to take pressure off with your
foot footwork where there's no more
pressure that would smother your strike
okay so that's me taking pressure off he
could take pressure off too uh so let's
say he he comes in half-assed now he
starts to go back right and boom now now
your strikes will work again you get
that what you have to do is not do them
under a spinal displacement pressure
otherwise they will be smothered okay uh
it could be that he just came in with
one step like a strike on one step
strike on one step so he goes boom
that's all he's trying to do do you see
that and he stopped himself on that
strike so he's doing that again and I
come in and I'll hit my strike he
stopped my striking get smothered and I
didn't get over with it you guys
understand that all right so
um let's deal with that pressure first
or that lack of pressure he's stopping
himself he didn't do spinal displacement
okay
um and we'll do that one
so he he had that jab I'm gonna move to
the inside and pull on the hip right
here on the on the rib so my inward hand
sword is part Perry comes around and is
gonna track that shot in okay so we'll
do it again again if I don't move at all
I'm not smothered you see
I had to get to that sweet spot so where
I can hit that and project through his
body I don't want you breaking wrists
but I want you to at least kind of Pop
him a little with your Coq
okay all right here we go okay uh when
you're dealing with strikes
um
you have to have an understanding that
you can't do my turn your turn
it's just
too painfully obvious but that truth is
actually present in all your throws too
uh in all your pins and all your net was
if the guy gets his stripe complete if
it's fully manifested before you start
your action that opening is not there
the same in uh the weapons so the Joe uh
the book in same thing if you wait for
that strike to be fully manifested
that's not actually that's the wrong
timing that's the wrong mind okay
um same thing goes with weapons too if
you if you don't start your draw at the
level of intention on someone who else
is drawing against you you're not gonna
get your handgun out it's not going to
work okay so we'll go slow here so you
could see uh what's happening is I am
going to hit him uh before that thing
reaches full extension I've already
started my strike because he's going to
pull that jab back that's what a jab
does and the target's gonna close you
see that so instead of going here and
I'm here and then he just sticks his
hand out but I'm like no one else will
do in reality
you gotta hit him
and strike is still going out that way
you see that
so stop training like this
it's in what you were hitting him as
he's coming back and that way the little
residual inertia that he had thinking he
was going to hit the target is going to
add to your opposing forces at the ribs
and to your Coq projection
okay that's what you're trying to do
boom you're gonna go slow and time it
boom
boom okay let's try it but you can't
have the hand sticking out there and
then you go go
so there's something now called
anatomical positioning but it assumes
that you have the actual power on your
strikes okay so when he's coming in
right boom I can move move him here that
that Force boom as I come in
I'm either I could throw it to displace
him do you see as I did there but you
can uh aim the power so that most of it
hits inside and you're trying to break
the ribs okay
um is he goes his body will do something
so if I if I hit here you see how it
came a little forward you see that okay
so you want to partner your strike stop
in light of that and you come a little
forward as I contoured under this arm
I'll Palm to her under over over the arm
right here oh I don't have the outward
hamstring
so and I get here and now when I when I
do those two things that are my gets
stuck out there and now I'll get my
angle cancellation this way okay boom
[Music]
so you hit it's very quick
okay and then the arm
s this you're not trying for katakatama
leave the elbow and you're working
against the joint
[Music]
okay let's go
so you can do that throw you can't do
that throw with classic or something you
can
okay your adhesion point just change but
you can do this though
look at what I'm working on here is this
one it's on the elbow
um and just note if your the ground is
going to hurt someone way harder than
any of your strikes ever could okay and
so in this case yeah I take the ground
but in order to make sure we learn this
other
Arm Control uh we're gonna use it to
continue the angle cancellation for more
stripes okay so we'll go back slow
and um boom pop I want here go roll it
over don't roll it over that's how you
get into cutting atomic
lock it in you have a friction Point
here your Ike's there and you have your
ikey here you keep those pressures so
that we can now just use this to slam my
him into my knee
so slow back down
boom here
okay try it